[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de senna 360
voici les titres
la proposition de loi anticasseurs sur
le point d'être adoptée par le sénat
après un parcours législatif chaotique
ponctuée hier par un nouveau
rebondissement avec la saisine du
conseil constitutionnel par ni par
l'elysée
tout est les réactions les explications
à suivre jacques toubon on s'inquiète du
renforcement de la répression en france
dans son rapport annuel
le défenseur des droits à pointe aussi
un repli des services publics qui selon
lui ce la cohésion sociale vous
l'entendrez dans un instant pas séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est dans 15 minutes sur notre antenne
le gouvernement sera interrogé sur la
situation en algérie au lendemain du
retrait de la candidature d'abdelaziz
bouteflika
un cinquième mandat vécue par la rue
comme une ruse pour se maintenir au
pouvoir
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir sur twitter avec le hashtag et
ses mains 360 pour m'accompagner
cet après midi on retrouvera atteindra
nuit salle des conférences et lexandre
poussard en direct de l'hémicycle
le multiplex politique et parlementaire
c'est tout
et on va justement prendre la direction
de l'hémicycle où nous attend alexandre
poussard alexandre bonjour je le disais
en titre on va vers un vote une adoption
définitive par le parlement de cette
proposition de loi anti casseurs après
un ultime vote du sénat le texte est en
discussion depuis deux heures où en
est-on dans le débat à la haute
assemblée
écoutez delphine la discussion générale
de cette proposition de loi vient de se
terminer à l'instant une discussion
générale initiée par christophe castaner
le ministre de l'intérieur qui attendait
qui a tenté d'apaiser les débats avec
les sénateurs et la remercie à plusieurs
reprises la droite du sénat à
l'initiative de cette proposition de loi
et qu'ils devraient voter conformes les
mesures issues du travail de l'assemblée
nationale alors christophe castaner a
dénoncé évidemment les casseurs et puis
il a tenté d'expliquer la décision d'
emmanuel macron de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel sur ce texte
écoutez le je suis convaincue par ce
texte mais je crois qu'en matière de
libertés publiques toutes les garanties
doivent être prises cette conviction je
les portais et je suis heureux que le
président de la république ait fait part
de sa volonté
une fois ce texte adopté définitivement
et sans présumer de l'intention du sénat
de le soumettre au conseil
constitutionnel
cette saisine permettra de lever les
doutes elle permettra de lever tous les
soupçons
car détourner le regard s'est donnée à
laisser détruire à quelques brutes ne
rien faire c'est permettre à quelques
ultraviolents de menacer nos vies nos
institutions et même notre liberté
décision du président de la république a
été vivement critiquée par les sénateurs
qui y voit une ingérence dans le travail
du parlement et du côté de la gauche du
sénat les groupes communistes et
socialistes ont défendu deux motion de
rejet de ce texte qu'ils jugent
liberticide
écoutez eliane assassi la présidente du
groupe communiste au sénat les
modifications apportées par la majorité
de l'assemblée nationale au texte
sénatorial ont provoqué un dérapage
incontrôlé la décision d' emmanuel
macron de saisir lui-même le conseil
constitutionnel se rapproche de la
sortie de route
emmanuel macron est piégé par un texte
de circonstance qui visait à tenter de
diaboliser le mouvement des gilet jaune
pour tenter de reprendre la main à tout
prix a donc accouché d'un
monstre juridique nous appelons
solennellement le sénat à prendre ses
responsabilités en votant
l'irrecevabilité
alors sans surprise la droite du sénat
n'a pas adopté ces deux motions de rejet
mais cela ne préjuge pas d'un débat
serein avec le gouvernement les airs tic
seront examinées en fin d'après midi
après les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre pour vos
précisions et vous met effectivement
d'en parler la saisine surprise hier par
le chef de l'état du conseil
constitutionnel sur les articles les
plus sensibles de ce texte a pris cours
la droite sénatoriale pour rappel elle
avait fait le choix d'un vote conforme à
celui des députés pour accélérer le
processus législatif de cette
proposition de loi les explications le
25 à lui c'est en quelques mots que
l'annoncé a été faite hier à la sortie
du conseil des ministres par le porte
parole du gouvernement à la veille d'un
vote qui s'annonce conforme au sénat sur
la proposition de loi anti casseurs
emmanuel macron prend les devants et le
présent de la république a donc informé
le gouvernement de son intention de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
il est ainsi pleinement dans son rôle de
garant des libertés publiques dans notre
pays une annonce qui a surpris car si la
proposition de loi a bien été voté
d'abord ici au sénat à l'automne la
majorité en marche la remanier puis
adopté à l'assemblée nationale en
février dernier mais lors de cet examen
cinquante députés de la majorité avaient
manqué à l'appel
en s'abstenant sur le texte selon eux la
loi anti-casseurs allé trop loin en
particulier sur l'article 2 et les
interdictions de manifester selon les
sénateurs aient l'air en saisissant le
conseil constitutionnel
il s'agissait donc de rassurer les
marcheurs les plus défavorables aux
textes et il veut répondre aux questions
à l'intérieur même du groupe en marche à
l'assemblée nationale et ça c'est
stupéfiant parce qu'en fait on a un
président qui n'a pas de cap et qui
n'est plus en mesure de donner un cap à
sa majorité
alors que la france les français et des
forces de l'ordre ont en plus besoin que
jamais d'avoir un cap et d'un président
exécutif qui le tiennent à gauche on
salue la démarche du président la
république socialiste et communiste sont
opposés au texte dans les deux chambres
du parlement
des groupes qui se préparait d'ailleurs
à déposer leur propre recours au conseil
constitutionnel lequel et la filiation
de ce texte il est présenté par repris
par le gouvernement présenté par edouard
philippe endossé par une majorité
l'assemblée nationale des avoués d'une
certaine manière par le président de la
république on n'y comprend plus rien des
sénateurs enfin qui pour certains
s'étonnent également de l'ingérence dans
le processus parlementaire par le
président de la république alors que le
texte anti casseurs n'est pas encore
définitivement adopté et on retourne la
salle des conférences pour une réaction
avec vous est en train de nuit avec les
sénateurs socialistes oui jérôme durand
vous êtes très opposés à cette
proposition de loi dite anti un casseur
est ce que vous vous réjouissez que le
président de la république annonce
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
le choix du calendrier est un peu
étrange à la veille de
de cette lecture au sénat de cette ppl
qu'on peut dire retailleau castaner
prendre l'initiative de ces halles
constitutionnel s'est envoyé un message
un peu étrange
il ya beaucoup d'arrières pensées
politiques et beaucoup d'hypocrisie sur
un sujet qui est pourtant extrêmement
important c'est les libertés publiques
c'est quand même le risque d'une forme
d'arbitraire je pense que personne ne
joue franc jeu sur cette affaire vous
dites qu'il ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie
qu'est ce que vous dénoncez très
exactement soyez clair écoutez ici
l'heure anglaise en première lecture
nous dit qu'en gros la ppl retailleau
n'aurait rien changé aux violences lors
des premières manifestations des gilets
jaunes
les républicains disent ce texte
finalement sans doute
inconstitutionnelle mais on va l'adopter
conforme
voilà donc à des calculs politiques et
tous les côtés oui tout à côté puissance
c'est un sujet sérieux
il ya quand même des risques pour des
manifestants il ya une autorisation
administrative de de matériel sur les
ministres hâtive de manifs et l'article
qui est quand même un acte assez lourd
donc je pense que le débat le bricolage
législatif auquel n'assistait pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
êtes vous surpris que d'ailleurs
philippe bas le président les
républicains de la commission des lois
disent comprendre la saisine du
président de la république pour lui
aussi cet article 2 sur l'interdiction
administrative de manifester va trop
loin
mais bien sûr qu'elle va trop loin cette
interdiction administrative de
manifester est d'ailleurs vient clash au
sein de l air donc sur ce sujet non je
pense qu'ils partagent tous le même
calcul politique mais le film a dit lui
même que la constitutionnalité du texte
est douteuse donc arrêtons cette
hypocrisie ne votons pas conformes et
travaillons pour améliorer ce texte nous
nous pensons qu'il est dangereux
nous l'avons dit nous défendrons la
pression jusqu'au bout quels sont pour
vous les points qui posent le plus
problème au sein de ses textes
outre l'interdiction administrative de
manifester ajouté
la dissimulation du visage telle est à
thouars les plaqués sur des périmètres
la question de la durée à la fin des
fouilles aussi fouilles évidemment à la
fin des fins on vide le judiciaire
on transfère sa la police administrative
c'est dangereux je reprendrai pas ce
qu'a dit charles de courson
mais on n'a que deux lettres qui a dit
jacques toubon évidemment évidemment
évidemment on nous dit tout à l'heure en
séance ce sont les gauche qui s'oppose
non les centristes sont très réservés
charles de courson est très réservé
nombre d'organisations internationales
sont très réservés
et le défenseur des droits chiffres à
l'appui donc ce texte est mauvais nous
voterons contre
eh bien merci beaucoup jérôme durain
d'avoir répondu à mes questions merci à
vous au tam pour cette première réaction
est justement vous en parliez jacques
toubon le défenseur des droits est bien
pour lui la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel est une excellente chose
je vous propose de l'écouter l'été tomic
en 2004 spielberg ce matin pour
l'article qui prévoit l'interdiction
administrative de manifester nous avons
alerté les parlementaires nous avons dit
il nous paraît y avoir des risques à la
fois constitutionnel par rapport aux
principes de notre constitution la
liberté d'aller et de venir liberté de
manifester et des risques qu'on appelle
conventionnelle c'est à dire par rapport
aux principes de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et je
suis donc aujourd'hui très satisfait de
voir que le président de la république a
en vertu des dispositions de la
constitution demandé que avant la
promulgation après le vote puis interné
marc aujourd'hui et avant la
promulgation de ce qui va devenir une
loi
le conte sectionnelles soit saisi je
vois dans la décision du président de la
république je dirais si je me place de
mon point de vue un certain certaine
considération pour les droits
fondamentaux qui me satisfait tout à
fait et jacques toubon présenté ce matin
son rapport annuel en tant que défenseur
des droits pour lui le constat est sans
appel la répression est en hausse en
france alors que les français
s'inquiètent d'un repli des services
publics sur fond de crise des gilets
jaunes michael sonberg
il se considère comme le sismographe de
la demande sociale jacques toubon le
défenseur des droits met l'accent dans
son rapport annuel sur la question de
l'accès aux services puis
cliquer sur les quelques cent mille
réclamations reçues en 2018 plus de la
moitié ont concerné les relations des
citoyens avec les services publics des
services toujours plus connecté
dématérialisée est synonyme pour
certains d'exclusion numérique c'est
qu'une organisation des services publics
des procédures des effectifs qu'ils font
qu' il y a de moins en moins de présence
humaine dans les services publics dans
les administrations et ce que j'ai dit
en ce qui concerne la numérisation
c'est qu'il existait 20 à 25% de la
population qui ne peut pas accéder aux
services publics et donc à ses droits à
travers des demandes en ligne pas de
réquisitoire contre la numérisation des
services publics mais le défenseur des
droits recommande un meilleur
accompagnement des personnes les plus en
difficulté il faut faire le nécessaire
pour que les services sociaux en
particulier qui ont parmi leurs usagers
une proportion très importante de
personnes en difficulté de familles en
difficulté voilà le genre même de
personnes auxquelles il faut apporter
une aide particulière si on le fait la
numérisation et la dématérialisation qui
est un progrès réussira sinon elle sera
une cause de division une cause
d'exclusion pour jacques toubon la
réforme des services publics ne doit pas
seulement être comptable mais prendre en
compte les usages est une nécessité afin
de lutter contre les sentiments
d'inégalité et d'injustice et on
continue des réactions avec vous êtes en
train de lui vous êtes au côté du
sénateur et l'air de paris pierre charon
c'est à vous oui cachard on va reparler
ensemble de la proposition de loi anti
cassant votre réaction au fait que le
président de la république s'apprête à
saisir le conseil constitutionnel pour
un certain nombre d'articles
d'abord c'est la deuxième fois dans
l'histoire de la vème république qu'un
président de la république saisi le
conseil constitutionnel contre sa propre
majorité et son gouvernement
il aurait pu avoir l'élégance
l'attendent le vote du sénat qui va
intervenir dans quelques heures
il n'a pas attendu mes connaissances un
peu de punch et mettant ça sur le dollar
bien sûr alors il ya quelques marcheurs
qui ne sont pas d'accord
enfin le premier ministre est mise à
l'intérieur que je vais interpeller tout
à l'heure sont d'accord sur cet article
c'est là où je comprends pas comment il
fait ça on a entendu effectivement
christophe castaner tout à leur rendre
hommage au travail qui a été effectué
par la droite sénatoriale absence est un
petit peu d'articles de salle en salle
c'est lui l'article 2 et le renforcement
l'article 2 et nous le sommes très
contents de ça oui effectivement
l'article 2 sur lesquels est bien le
président la république veut une saisine
du conseil constitutionnel et qui porte
sur l'interdiction administrative de
manifester le président l ère de la
commission de la philly pas jojo lui lui
aussi qu'il va trop loin cet article
qu'il ya des risques constitutionnels
ce qui compte c'est ce qui a dû être
votée tout à l'heure et la maladresse du
président de la république saisissant on
est tous d'accord là-dessus en réunion
de groupe ce matin c'était le cas sur la
saisine du conseil constitutionnel
travaux le principe avant le vote du
sénat
il faut attendre je comprends très bien
qu'il veuille faire ça je suis quand
même assez rare le dernier qu'il a fait
c'est monsieur hollande est sur lui a
pas porté bonheur
c'est aussi une réponse peut-être du
présent la république au sénat qui sabre
est a voté conforme au texte qu'ils
avaient par ailleurs critiqué lorsqu'il
était à l'assemblée nationale vous aviez
jugé que la copie de l'assemblée était
moins bien moins bonne que celle du
sénat c'est l'intérêt d'être
majoritaires au sénat c'est que nous
reprenons les textes où les modifiant
nous les votons ayant le rethel qu'elle
est là on a une belle occasion de le
faire
en plus quand ce retailleau a proposé 7
ce texte ça a été fait non pas avec les
gilet jaune cet effet avant c'était en
réaction à ce qui se passait à nantes
avec les casseurs dans les villes et à
paris au début c'était là dessus donc on
est tout à fait décontractée par rapport
à l'urgence n'est pas dans l'urgence
qu'on a fait ce texte pour conclure
jacques toubon dénonce un renforcement
de la répression en france et demande
est bien à nouveau l'interdiction des
lbd votre réaction à cette demande a
répondu à ça on est tous d'accord
gouvernement et opposition aux positions
nationales les majorité sénatoriale pour
conserver cette cette arme
autant que faire se peut pour éviter les
armes létales en face quand même la
moindre des choses quand on lance des
boules de pétanque ou quand on voit des
cocktails molotov sur la tête des
policiers
il faut pas s'attendre un simplement un
petit jet de gaz lacrymogène il faut
quand même que notre réponse bien merci
à beaucoup pierre charon d'avoir répondu
à mes questions merci madame merci à
vous tourner dans l'hémicycle puisque la
séance de questions d'actualité va
débuter dans quelques instants quel est
l'ordre du jour alexandre pousse à
écouter delphine on va parler de la
crise en algérie puisque les sénateurs
vont interroger le gouvernement sur
cette crise
alors que le président algérien
abdelaziz bouteflika a renoncé hier à
briguer un cinquième mandat face aux
manifestations de la population un
renoncement en renoncement qui a été
saluée aujourd'hui par emmanuel macron
le président français a appelé je cite à
une transition durable alors que
l'élection présidentielle prévue le 18
avril en algérie a été reporté la date
de la prochaine présidentielle en
algérie doit être fixée par une
conférence nationale d'ici à la fin de
l'année 2019 et notez qu emmanuel macron
a aussi salué la gestion de ces
manifestations par la police algérienne
la cloche vient de sonner c'est le début
de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
au gouvernement elles sont retransmises
en direct sur public sénat sur notre
site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des uns
et des autres et aussi au temps de
parole et je donne la parole au
président jean claude requier pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
merci monsieur le président mais c'est
le premier ministre depuis le 21 février
dernier une grande partie du peuple
algérien est descendue dans la rue pour
s'opposer à un cinquième mandat du
président bouteflika dans un esprit
pacifique il faut le souligner cette
mobilisation inédite dans cette forme
depuis très longtemps a évidemment
contribué à faire évoluer les positions
du pouvoir d'abord lorsque le podium
bouteflika annoncé s'il ne terminerait
pas son second mandat s'il venait à être
réélu
puis hier soir lorsqu'il a annoncé
qu'ils renonçaient à nouveau les
candidatures invoquant cette fois sonnac
et chanter si cette annonce satisfait à
court terme des revendications des
manifestants pour une modernisation
système politique
elles ne répondent pas aux attentes
fondamentales du peuple algérien le
soyons pas naïfs
quand aujourd'hui la contestation
pourrait évoluer j'arrive volonté un
changement plus large
le scrutin présidentiel devrait avoir
lieu après une conférence nationale
inclusive indépendante représentative
toutes les composantes de la société
avec pour mission d'élaborer dans cette
année un projet de constitution à
soumettre au référendum c'est qui
revient à reporter l'élection
présidentielle à une date non fixée le
président emmanuel macron accueilli avec
satisfaction ces annonces à plein au
passage en transition d'une durée
raisonnable
on le sait nos deux pays entretiennent
depuis longtemps des relations complexes
passionnel d'étroites pourriez où
monsieur le ministre nous préciser la
position de votre gouvernement
ces dernières évolutions pour vous
répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président
complexe passionnés ancien des relations
entre la france et l'algérie le sont en
effet parce que notre histoire est à
bien des égards une histoire commune
parce que elle a connu des moments de
lumière et des moments dhombres parce
que
l'algérie est notre voisine de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée parce qu'elle
est un état ami souverain est clé pour
la région pour toutes ces raisons nous
suivons avec beaucoup d'attention ce qui
se passe en algérie
je veux le dire mais je crois que
personne n'a évidemment de doute sur le
sujet l'algérie est un état souverain
nous respecte complètement cette
souveraineté et les évolutions récentes
de la situation nous impose et nous
recommande de rappeler toujours avec
force et avec clarté cette évidence
qu'il je viens d'évoquer
alors où en sommes-nous lendemain des
annonces du président bouteflika le
président bouteflika a fait savoir hier
dans son adresse ou dans son message à
la nation qu'il renonçait à se présenter
à l'élection présidentielle qui était
initialement prévu le 18 avril il a
proposé les jalons d'une rénovation du
système politique algérien avec un
remaniement ministériel qui s'est
traduit par la nomination d'un nouveau
premier ministre et d'un vice premier
ministre l'organisation d'une conférence
nationale dont les travaux doivent se
conclure d'ici la fin de l'année et
devrait déboucher sur l'adoption par
référendum d'une nouvelle constitution
et enfin et seulement après cela la
tenue d'élections présidentielles
auxquelles lui même ne serait pas
candidat voilà le contenu des annonces
nous avons salué ces derniers
développements d'abord parce que ces
annonces interviennent à l'issue de
plusieurs semaines de manifestations à
travers tout le pays qui ont vu des
millions d'algériens et d'algériennes
exprimé dans le calme dans la dignité
leurs aspirations
nous notons aussi que ce civisme des
manifestants a été contemporain d'une
grande retenue des forces de l'ordre
lesquelles ont été exemplaires
nous souhaitons que cet esprit de
responsabilité qui a été noté par
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale puisse perdurer la fac se
mettent en place les conditions d'une
solution démocratique qui doit
maintenant s'engager c'est
une dynamique à même de répondre aux
aspirations profondes du peuple algérien
et surtout la mise en place d'un
calendrier politique de transition
raisonnable puisque l'affichage et le
respect de ce calendrier est une
condition de crédibilité est essentielle
à l'ensemble du processus
c'est le voeu que nous formons nous qui
souhaitons une algérie stable prospère
et unie
c'est d'abord la responsabilité des
algériens eux-mêmes
nous le disons en toute amitié et avec
toute l'attention qui est la nôtre sur
la situation actuelle
merci monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président hockey oui
viry d'algérie monsieur le polémiste
ouais c'est le fil du rasoir entre les
accusations des gérants circulation des
différences quant au peuple algérien
je ne l'achète pas que six listes pour
lui cette réflexion de guise et et
tomasi di lampedusa extrait du départ il
faut que tu bouges pour que rien ne
change
merci monsieur le président
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
cathy apourceau poly pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes pour deux minutes
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le sénat a rejeté massivement
la privatisation d'aéroports de paris
mais votre gouvernement s'entête à
l'assemblée nationale à brader ce bien
public
un entêtement qui éveille bien des
soupes sont tant vos arguments peine à
convaincre le privé sur le sort est
selon-vous meilleurs gestionnaires que
le public
faux adp le deuxième groupe
aéroportuaire d'europe en passe de
devenir le premier selon de nombreuses
études
l'état n'aurait pas vocation à entrer
dans le jeu concurrentiel pourtant vous
proposer de privatiser un service public
national doublé d'un monopole naturel il
faut 250 millions d'euros pour financer
le fonds pour l'innovation
or à des pnj et la française des jeux
tout privatisé par la loi pacte c'est
plus de 700 millions d'euros de
dividendes et que dire des recettes qui
pourrait être attendue d'un
rétablissement de l'iace f l'état
gardera-t-il une part du capital d'adp
et p à la veille de la privatisation
rien n'est encore décidé enfin vous ne
tirez pas la leçon de l'avis du
rapporteur public de la cour
administrative d'appel de paris qui
préconise après les critiques acerbes de
la cour des comptes
l'annulation de la privatisation au
combien douteuses de l'aéroport de
toulouse dès lors loin de la théorie du
complot il s'agit monsieur madame la
ministre de donner des réponses claires
à la représentation nationale et à nos
concitoyens qui ne comprennent pas qu'on
puisse les spoliés dans la durée damien
d'altérer nationales stratégiques
financées par l'argent du peuple
la vérité doit être dite madame la
ministre vinci n'a pas eu notre dame des
landes mais recevra une part d un
milliard d'euros qui sera versée aux
actuels actionnaires minoritaires oui ou
non madame lamy
east vinci utilisera-t-il l'argent
public pour acheter des biens du peuple
quand vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur benjamin griveaux secrétaire
d'état auprès du premier ministre porte
parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice en cédant ses
participations publiques dans certaines
grandes entreprises l'état le
gouvernement fait le choix responsables
d'investir dans l'avenir
c'est ce que nous faisons avec les
recettes attendues des différentes
cessions de participation pour un
montant de 10 milliards d'euros au total
qui va aller abonder le fonds pour
l'innovation de rupture afin d'investir
dans la recherche dans l'innovation dans
l'intelligence artificielle pour que
pour que les google
les facebook les amazones les tesla des
années 2030 ne soient pas tous
américains
mais français français et européens
cette cession de participation se fera
et vous le savez malade la paix de
sénatrice est inscrit dans la loi
avec de nombreuses garanties des
garanties financières puisque l'état
réalisera ses devants tôt meilleures
conditions de marché que le produit de
cession devra être très supérieur à la
somme des dividendes actualisée nette
futur
sinon il n'y aura pas de session enfin
les acheteurs devront remplir des
conditions strictes concernant les fonds
propres est également présente et de
l'expérience dans le secteur aérien des
garanties également de contrôle et de
sanctions renforcées pour l'état sur les
investissements sur les tarifs et sur la
qualité du service des garanties
également sur la sécurité les fonctions
régaliennes de l'état qui ont trait soit
la sécurité des biens soit la sécurité
des personnes seront bien évidemment
assurée par l'état des garanties enfin
patrimoniale puisque l'état récupérera
vous le savez c'est inscrit dans le
texte
l'ensemble des infrastructures des
aéroports de paris à l'issue d'une
concession de 70 ans
enfin madame la sénatrice puisque
le sénat et la chambre de territoire il
ya aussi dans cet accord des garanties
territoriales pour les habitants pour
les communes avoisinantes
en termes de qualité de la desserte
ferroviaire de ce territoire important
pour l'ile-de-france et pour notre pays
jour merci merci la parole est à
monsieur notre collègue christian
manable pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique est la grande
cause de notre époque et du futur et le
structure de plus en plus le débat
politique en cours ou en contre et le
structure aussi les relations
internationales
notre pays je le rappelle a été un
exemple avec la signature de l'accord de
paris il ya plus de trois ans mais force
est de constater que nous sommes face à
une impuissance quand les etats unis se
retirent de la corde paris et aussi face
chez nous en france il faut bien le dire
à une relative inaction
quand nous écoutons l'ex ministre
nicolas hulot qui faisait part de son
désarroi
en septembre dernier face à cela nous
voyons des jeunes partout dans le monde
qui ont bien compris l'urgence et
appelle un profond changement de braquet
pour que notre société gagne ce combat
en février déjà de nombreux lycéens et
étudiants notre pays ont rejoint ce
mouvement de grève pour agir pour le
climat ce vendredi selon toute
vraisemblance le mouvement devrait
simplifier chez les jeunes avant de
nouvelles marches pour le climat le
week-end prochain
ce mouvement de jeunesse spontanée et
internationale doit faire réagir les
pouvoirs publics
il est temps non seulement de comprendre
l'inquiétude de ces jeunes mais aussi
l'aspiration un changement global clair
un engagement forte de notre société
face à cet élan de la jeunesse aussi
généreux que lucide aussi monsieur le
premier ministre nous avons bien vu que
l'éducation nationale organisera des
débats dans les lycées pour faire
remonter les idées des lycéens sur ce
sujet alors je le précise au passage
qu'en même temps vous repoussez le
projet de loi sur l'énergie
c'est un véritable paradoxe alors voilà
mes questions
quelles sont vos idées quelles sont vos
propositions pour inverser ou du moins
pour contenir le réchauffement
climatique qui n'est pas un fantasme
le professeur caussinus mais bien une
réalité quelles mesures allez vous
prendre pour que la france respecte ses
engagements de 2015 et enfin quelles
actions en europe pour qu'enfin notre
société avance et ne reste pas
silencieuse
en attendant que survienne la
catastrophe merci son intention apparent
les communistes de l'éducation nationale
de la jeunesse jean michel blanquer vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur manable votre question est
évidemment très importante et c'est une
question qui doit nous unir dans tout le
pays puisque le sujet de changement
climatique et de la biodiversité et de
l'environnement en général sont
évidemment des sujets clés et il est
normal que ce soit la jeunesse qui se
sentent plus particulièrement concernés
tout particulièrement concerné puisque
par définition c'est elle qui était
encore plus concerné par le futur et
c'est un mouvement qu'on voit dans le
monde et c'est un mouvement qu'il faut
encourager parce que en effet on a
besoin de cette mobilisation mondiale de
tous en réalité mais notamment des
jeunes pour qu'il y ait non seulement
sensibilisation mais surtout solution
est alors vous m'interrogez sur
finalement ce que peuvent être ces
solutions et je pense que compter sur la
jeunesse est une des voies par la seule
bien sûr pour avoir des solutions
j'étais ce matin même à tour dans un
débat justement dans le cadre du grand
débat avec des jeunes d'une école de la
deuxième chance
et lorsqu'on assiste pendant un temps
long à ces échanges on voit bien que
chacun a des idées pour le quotidien et
qu'il faut structurer ses idées pour le
futur
nous ne partons pas de zéro beaucoup a
été fait depuis une quinzaine d'années
pour que dans les programmes de l'école
le développement durable soit centrale
nous devons maintenant mettre en action
l'ensemble des citoyens et la jeunesse
nous avons aujourd'hui un label dans nos
établissements que nous appelons le 3d
qui permet aux élèves de se mobiliser
eux mêmes pour trouver des solutions
récemment j'étais à conflans sainte
honorine où les élèves ont fait baisser
au monde divisé de moitié la baisse la
part dont la facture énergétique de leur
établissement leur vision sur la lumière
le chauffage les enjeux quotidiens de
l'environnement est en train
d'influencer leur commune leur famille
leur environnement ils peuvent donc être
les vecteurs de ce changement concret au
quotidien ils ont dû aussi des idées à
l'échelle nationale et à l'échelle
internationale l'échelle européenne est
aussi très importante nous rappelions ce
matin que trois directives ont été
adoptées à la fin de l'année 2018 pour
mettre fin à trois pesticides qui était
tueur d'abeilles
il ya donc des progrès qu'ils ont
accomplis ils se font grâce à la
mobilisation de des citoyens du
gouvernement mais croyez-le ce qui va se
passer vendredi aura beaucoup
d'importance puisque le 5 avril prochain
nous réunirons l'ensemble des des
représentants lycéens de france pour
précisément structurer ses propositions
de la jeunesse merci la parole est à
notre collègue alain fouché pour le
groupe les indépendants république et
territoires
clavé deux minutes monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ma question porte sur l'accompagnement
des entreprises qui subissent la crise
du diesel en sept ans la part du diesel
est passé en france de 73 à 35% et sous
traitants souffrent notamment ceux de
renault quinze mille emplois sur les 38
milles de la filière sont menacés en
juillet 2018 j'ai interrogé monsieur le
maire et s'est engagé à accompagner les
industries pour défendre des emplois
dont celle des fonderies du poitou
implantée à châtellerault il a annoncé
que le fonds des industriels doté de 10
milliards d'euros financerait la
diversification de ces entreprises dont
des fonderies le 16 octobre à
l'assemblée s'est à nouveau engagé à
accompagner la transformation des
fonderies il a dit nous y arrivons et il
m'a dit invités moi je viendrai cons et
ils six mois après il n'est jamais venu
malgré les invitations répétées dont
celle de jean pierre abelin président du
grand châtellerault vous seule madame la
ministre avait eu le courage de venir
sur place ces derniers jours merci mais
aucune stratégie industrielle est
annoncé renault financera ces deux
entreprises pendant le redressement
judiciaire l'état est actionnaire est
son engagement obtenues l'offre de
reprise qui a votre soutien prévoit de
ne conserver qu'un emploi sur deux tout
en faisant appel à des intérimaires pour
honorer les commandes
ce n'est pas sérieux hier vous avez
unis les constructeurs équipementiers
syndicats et des présidents de région
belle initiative
il faut que cela débouche sur des
mesures concrètes après un an de crise
pour vous rassurer les 850 salariés
l'état va-t-il continuer à faire
pression sur renault
allez vous utiliser les fonds des
industriels pour consolider les offres
de reprise de ces deux sites
allez-vous réhabiliter le diesel propre
moins polluants aujourd'hui que
l'essence répondre elle la parole et
qu'à madame agnès pannier rue nash et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur fouché
comme vous l'avez dit j'étais
effectivement vendredi un grande pour
visiter la fonderie saint jean
industries et la fonderie du poitou
nous avons ensemble revu les conditions
de travail sur ce dossier j'ai pu
rappeler l'action du gouvernement qui
explique qu'aujourd'hui ces deux sites
continuent à tourner que les 800
salariés ou un peu moins continue
d'avoir un travail et que trois
repreneurs sont aujourd'hui en lice
comme vous le savez pour reprendre ses
deux fonderies et réunir en un seul site
ceux qui étaient deux sites et nuisait à
la compétitivité des deux des deux
industries je voudrais également
rappeler que si l'état n'avait pas été
là il n'y aurait pas eu 6 millions de
soutien de passif social au cours de
l'été ni si mis un peu plus de 6
millions ni si mignon de soutien de la
part de renault
je voudrais également rappeler que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une discussion
avec les repreneurs et une discussion
serrée nous consolidons le plan nous
avons deux rendez vous importants le 19
et le 21 mars pour pouvoir obtenir un
avis des deux tribunal de commerce a
dans un dans une course contre la montre
puisque nous devons réunir les deux
dossiers ensemble je pense que grâce à
l'action du gouvernement nous allons
sortir avec une solution une solution
solide avec renault est effectivement en
imposant un certain nombre de choses à
renault et vous citez la réunion de
lundi dernier je voudrais rappeler que
suite à votre questionnement sur le
diesel propre
nous avons pris une décision lundi nous
prise parce que nous estimons que l'état
doit être neutre technologiquement et
nous partageons cette vision avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement neutre
technologiquement ça veut dire pas en
rabattre sur les exigences vis-à-vis des
motorisations il faut qu'elles soient
les plus propres possibles mais ici deux
moteurs ou les mêmes performances en
conditions réelles et mesurée par des
tiers et pas par les constructeurs
alors qu'ils seront nous pour leur
empêché de bénéficier des mêmes des
mêmes règles du jeu donc vous voilà
voilà une réponse précise à une question
qui était posée le vendredi et que vous
avez le lundi je suis confiante sur le
fait qu'on trouve une solution pour ces
deux sites et qu'on maintienne avec
renault le poids de 8,2 des personnes
500 personnes a minima sans merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
pascale gruny du reste est du tonga
merci monsieur le président pour le
groupe l'est républicain la parole ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
monsieur le ministre
'l'annonce d'une baisse drastique du
budget de la politique agricole commune
dit pacte a été ressentie comme une onde
de choc
elle se traduira par une perte d'environ
8 milliards d'euros pour l'agriculture
française et pas seulement à cause du
grès xiti quels revenus pour nos
agriculteurs demain
plus grave encore dans le nouveau modèle
imaginé par la commission européenne
ce sont désormais les états qui
définiront en grande partie les
conditions à respecter pour bénéficier
des aides agricoles
c'est donc le risque d'une
renationalisation de la pac c'est à dire
un retour à 27 politiques agricoles
nationales différentes
un tel scénario signifierait toujours
plus de concurrence avec nos voisins
toujours plus de contrôle de la
commission européenne toujours plus de
complexité
le 14 février dernier les commissions
des affaires européennes et économiques
du sénat ont adopté à l'unanimité une
nouvelle proposition de résolution
européenne sur la pac
monsieur le ministre allez vous saisir
cette ultime opportunité pour remettre à
plat cette réforme de la pac mal engagée
aucun président de la république aucun
des ministres qui vous
ont précédé n'ont cédé sur la pac alors
que l'inde la chine ou les états unis
n'hésitent pas à mettre un pognon de
dengue dans leur agriculture
ne laissez pas l'histoire se souvenir de
vous comme le ministre qui aura fait
renoncer la france et l'europe à leurs
ambitions agricoles
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au ministre de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation monsieur
didier guillaume sur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices je
voudrais d'abord en mon nom personnel
féliciter mon ami jean yves roux votre
collection nature qui est d'être papa
aujourd'hui je pense que ça mérite
d'être saluée dans cette dans cet
hémicycle et et et dire et dire à madame
la sénatrice gruny que le gouvernement
partage votre votre vision votre
ambition mais si je peux me permettre ce
que vous dites n'est pas réel la
question la question du budget de la pac
et c'est pour ça qu'il ne faut pas que
vous cédiez vous aux sirènes ultra
libérale de la commission le budget de
la pac la france ne veut pas tel qu'il
est présenté par la commission comme 20
autres pays de l'union européenne n'en
veulent pas tel qu'il est présenté par
la commission -4 9% de baisse sur le 1er
pilier -15% sur le 2e pilier
c'est absolument inacceptable c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président de la
république l'a dit lors de
l'inauguration de son agriculture
le premier ministre ne cesse de le
rappeler la france n'accepte pas cette
diminution
cela dit il faut qu'à un mètre objectif
le budget de la pac baissera à due
concurrence du retrait du royaume uni de
l'union européenne
dire que le budget de la pac ne
diminuera pas est un affreux mensonge
mais il n'est pas question que nous
acceptions que le budget de la politique
agricole commune baisse plus que le
montant de 2,2 du retrait de l'union 2
des britanniques parce que ça serait
faire peser sur la première politique
intégrée européenne le poids d'autres
politiques
deuxième chose nous allons bien
repréciser dans l'appel de madrid de ces
20 pays qui n'acceptent pas la baisse du
budget de la politique agricole commune
qu'il était hors de question que la pac
soit renationaliser c'est la première
politique intégrée européenne elle doit
rester dans le cadre européen
et là dessus je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
sujet aussi bien la commission que le
parlement que les états de l'union sont
favorables à ce que ça reste de la sorte
et troisième point nous allons attaquer
à nouveau de nouvelles discussions après
le départ du royaume uni afin de voir ce
que nous mettrons dans la politique
agricole commune mais nous en
reparlerons dans une prochaine séance de
questions merci merci monsieur louis
nicollin julie oui merci monsieur le
président je suis contente de vous
entendre mais j'aimerais bien avoir des
désaccords parce que nos inquiétudes
elles sont elles sont fondées quand même
le 24 mai dernier nous avions reçu le
commissaire oettinger qui disait qu'en
fait que la france avait un discours ici
et un autre discours en fait qui a
accepté la baisse du budget donc on est
habitué au double langage
alors on a vu bien entendu au salon de
l'agriculture un discours magnifique du
président de l'agriculture mais nous on
veut autre chose et les agriculteurs
sont attendus sur autre chose des actes
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue nadia sur
le goupe pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole matière
collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues à côté du
15 mars
c'est à dire dans trois jours toutes les
prises en charge des formations des
chefs d'entreprises artisanales seront
suspendus aucune nouvelle demande ne
pourrait être honorées seuls les
dossiers agréés avancé date
bénéficieront d'un financement
ceci à cause de plusieurs erreurs qui
auraient pu être évités avec un minimum
de préparation
la refonte du système de recouvrement de
la contribution à la formation
professionnelle a entraîné un
assèchement de la collecte qui est passé
de 72 millions l'an passé à 40 millions
cette année
cette situation s'impose de façon
brutale à tous les organismes de
formations qu'aux professionnels
concernés qui se trouve dans une
position critique étranglée nous sommes
nombreux à avoir été saisi de ce
scandale par les chambres des métiers
des syndicats professionnels les
organismes de formation bref toutes les
organisations professionnelles
extrêmement inquiète
la formation professionnelle est
essentiel à nos entreprises artisanales
on ne peut imaginer qu'elle soit
suspendue jusqu'à une date indéterminée
mettant par la même occasion de nombreux
emplois en péril face à cette urgence je
souhaite savoir madame la ministre
quelle mesure vous comptez prendre afin
de pallier à cette situation
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame agnès pannier venait chez mis les
finances
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice vous m'interrogez
sur la situation de la collecte de la
contribution à la formation
professionnelle des artisans comme vous
le savez depuis dix 2018 elle est
assurée par les urssaf et non plus par
la direction générale des finances
publiques en application la loi travail
cette modification des modalités
techniques de collecte a entraîné des
difficultés de trésorerie pour le fonds
d'assurance formation des chefs
d'entreprises artisanales ainsi que pour
les conseils en formation en effet
l'ordre national des experts comptables
a eu une interprétation de cette
modification qui a conduit à bloquer ou
à inciter les artisans à ne pas payer
l'intégralité de la crosse et de la
cotisation de type était redevable et
cette confusion a induit la situation
que vous mentionnez qui est que là où on
attendait une conciliation de 42
millions d'euros
elle est de 9 millions d'euros alors
l'état des pas rester les bras croisés
l'agencé france trésor a avancé 15
millions d'euros l'acoss a avancé 18
millions d'euros il nous sommes en train
de discuter avec lui de paix et la cm à
pour trouver une solution
cette solution pardonnez-moi mais dans
la loi les chefs d'entreprise en
question sont bien recevable de ses
cotisations
après on peut essayer de trouver une
solution politique qui vise à pondérer
ces cotisations qui sont effectivement
importante avec la question de la
formation mais je pense que c'est un
sujet qui doit être réglé avec les
représentants de ces professions lui de
paix et la sema et c'est ce que nous
faisons
je vous remercie merci madame legault
oui madame la ministre à vrai dire le
problème de la collecte et du
recouvrement c'est pas notre souci
puisque là il s'agit d'un problème vous
l'avez dit de trésorerie si j'ai bien
compris ça fait pas encore la miley
situer les fonds vous avez trouvé
parce que on peut pas laisser les
artisans dans cette situation ce sont
pas assainis les organismes de formation
ni le fasse et annie les artisans qui
collecte les fonds c'est pas eux qui
sont responsables de cette situation et
l'état a été interpellé de façon
régulière sur le sujet depuis des mois
donc maintenant qu'on en est là l'état
doit trouver une solution à chacun son
rôle
à chacun ses responsabilités je remercie
merci la parole est notre collègue
patricia schellinger pour le groupe de
la république en marche
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des solidarités et de
la santé christelle du boss madame la
ministre c'est un fait la situation de
la pauvreté en france est très
préoccupante depuis de très nombreuses
années
9 millions de personnes vivant en
situation de pauvreté dont 3 millions
d'enfants
autant de situations d'exclusion et de
difficultés d'insertion
la délégation interministérielle à
laquelle j'ai participé ayant rendu ses
conclusions
il est temps de traduire dans les faits
le plan pauvreté alliant prévention et
accompagnement
c'est dans ce cadre que vous lancer les
travaux sur le revenu universel
d'activité l'objectif est d'améliorer la
protection sociale de lutter contre les
nombreux cours notamment en simplifiant
les démarches et en proposant une
refonte de certains minima sociaux tels
que le rsa la prime d'activité voire les
aides au logement
il faudra s'interroger sur l'ensemble
des personnes précaires les étudiants
retraités et je n'oublie pas le monde
agricole
ces travaux s'appuieront et un nom pas
douter sur des points de vue des acteurs
concernés tels que les caf les
collectivités territoriales les
associations de solidarité comme les
associations de chômeurs et précaires
si les contours restent bien sûr à
dessiner pouvez vous madame la ministre
nous apporter aujourd'hui peut-être des
précisions quant au calendrier aux
grands axes et à l'organisation générale
à venir pour vous répondre la parole et
à madame la secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des solidarités de santé de
la ville avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
mesdames et messieurs pardon les
sénateurs man la sénatrice le président
de la république a en effet annoncé en
septembre dernier la création du revenu
universel d'activité fusionnant le plus
grand nombre possible de prestations
comme vous le décrivez ce projet
nécessite une expertise très importante
c'est pourquoi je régnerait ce jeudi aux
côtés de fabrice lenglart nommée
rapporteure générale le comité inter
administratif destiné à lancer les
travaux techniques
la réforme que je porte est essentielle
elle doit permettre de mieux répondre à
cinq impératifs l'impératif de dignité
pour permettre à ceux qui n'ont pas ou
peu de revenus professionnels d'être
adéquatement protégés
l'impératif de simplicité d'accès au
droit pour lutter comme vous l'avez dit
contre le non recours au droit
l'impératif de transparence pour
permettre aux allocataires de prévoir
l'évolution de leurs revenus et les
inciter à reprendre une activité
l'impératif d'équité pour garantir
l'égalité de traitement aux personnes se
trouvant dans une situation équivalente
et enfin l'impératif de responsabilité
autour d'un contrat d'engagement
réciproque rénové entre l'état et les
bénéficiaires pour que chacun soit
accompagnée vers une activité
cette réforme sera d'une grande ampleur
est donc indispensable de mener un
travail collectif de concertation et d
analyse pour définir précisément les
contours et les paramètres de cette
future prestation
je souhaite que nous examinons tous les
différents scénarios de façon à ce
qu'aucun choix ne soit présenté de
nombreuses prestations sont
potentiellement concernées rsa apl prime
d'activité d'abord mais aussi minimum
vieillesse
aah ou la ss nous devrons aussi nous
poser la question des jeunes et de
l'intégration des jeunes dans ce
dispositif pour les 18 25 ans au-delà de
ces travaux techniques une concertation
institutionnels et citoyenne sera lancée
à partir du printemps 2010 9 du
printemps et pour toute l'année 2019
j'ai demandé à ce que cette concertation
associe toutes les parties prenantes
vous en avez citer quelques-unes les
collectivités les caf la msa les
associations mais aussi nos concitoyens
en ainsi j'ai envie toutes celles et
tous ceux qui le souhaitent à participer
à cette concertation pour écrire un
texte qui sera présenté en 2020 je vous
remercie
suivez le
ministre de même soulagé oui je tiens à
remercier le gouvernement et puis
féliciter madame la ministre
et oui et oui le gouvernement a entendu
un des messages du grand débat national
et en particulier une des réponses
apportées sur sur le pouvoir d'achat
merci madame namibie merci la parole est
à m collègues frédérique puissat pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma paroles s'adressaient à
madame la ministre du travail mme je
crois que c'est le porte parole du
gouvernement qui me répond monsieur le
ministre
l'échec de la négociation sur
l'assurance sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage était annoncé né de
la volonté du chef de l'état supportant
celle du gouvernement annoncé devant le
congrès de versailles concrétisée par le
dépôt d'un amendement tardif au moment
de l'examen du projet de loi pour la
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel par le sénat la
renégociation anticipée de la convention
d'assurance chômage alors que la
précédente ne datait que de juillet 2018
n'était pas placée sous les meilleurs
auspices déjà un sentiment d'absence de
respect du débat démocratique
les avis de nous parlementaires mais
également des partenaires sociaux laissé
planer une volonté de recentralisation
de l'assurance chômage par le
gouvernement
c'était une provocation que de demander
aux partenaires sociaux dans votre
lettre de cadrage 3 à 4 milliards
d'euros d'économies que vous ne riez pas
pu assumer politiquement alors que par
vos propres décisions en juillet ou fait
le choix délibéré d'aggraver le déficit
annuel de l'unedic de 500 millions
d'euros
c'était une provocation que de leur
demander de négocier sur un bonus malus
d'ores et déjà actée par le président de
la république
ma question est donc la suivante en
supprimant les cotisations chômage des
salariés pour les remplacer par de la
csg et volant d'une logique d'assurance
une logique de solidarité
n'avez-vous pas implicitement prémédité
la déresponsabilisation des syndicats
est tronqué une négociation à laquelle
vous n'avez peut-être vous même jamais
cru mais dont les conséquences s'il
quasiment la fin du paritarisme dans
notre pays
pour vous répondre d'abord le tous ces
facteurs d'état porte-parole du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole
il ya un merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs aussi un terreau
madame la sénatrice conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
république engagements qu'il a pris dans
le cadre de la campagne présidentielle
gouvernement a fait le choix de placer
de travail au coeur du projet politique
que nous portons
vous l'avez rappelé nous avons demandé
aux partenaires sociaux d'ouvrir une
négociation sur l'assurance chômage ces
négociations malheureusement n'ont pas
abouti nous le regrettons d'autant plus
que le gouvernement avait donné un délai
supplémentaire pour aboutir télé
supplémentaires donnés à la demande des
partenaires sociaux est question que
nous avions posé alors reste entière et
il appartient au gouvernement de
reprendre la main sur le dossier de
l'assurance chômage
nous le faisons en poursuivant deux
objectifs d'abord lutter contre la
précarité et ensuite inciter au retour à
l'emploi
cet enjeu de la transformation est
d'ailleurs double d'abord inciter les
entreprises à proposer des contrats de
travail plus long et privilégier les
embauches en cdi pour des précarisés et
ensuite toujours s'assurer que la
reprise d'emploi est plus intéressante
que le fait de rester au chômage de très
larges consultations ont été engagés par
muriel pénicaud avec les partenaires
sociaux avec les associations de
chômeurs avec l'émouvant d'employeurs
les parlementaires les organisations de
salariés y compris des organisations de
salariés non représentative et à l'issue
de ces consultations des mesures seront
présentées au printemps
elles feront l'objet d'un décret qui
sera mise en oeuvre cet été vous le
voyez madame la sénatrice
il n'ya dans l'action engagée par le
gouvernement nulle volonté de remettre
en question le paritarisme
mais il y a le souhait réel d'assumer
pleinement nos responsabilités lorsqu un
enjeu aussi crucial que l'emploi que la
lutte contre le chômage et contre le
chômage de longue durée est en jeu et
c'est à cela que nous allons nous
atteler je suis sûr que cela nous
pouvons nous en réjouir collectivement
je vous remercie si vous préférez cuit
chat
que l'on puisse s'en réjouir c'est une
certitude mais monsieur le ministre dans
un gouvernement il ya ce que l'on veut
bien nous laisser voir et il ya ce que
l'on voit et ce que l'on vit ce que l'on
voit ce que l'on vit et ce que l'on veut
bien nous laisser croire c'est matin
midi et soir un gouvernement qui
écouterait les français un gouvernement
qui écouterait les partenaires sociaux
un gouvernement qui écouterait les élus
qui écouterait les parlements mais ce
que nous vivons est bien différent en
fixant un tel cadre partenaires sociaux
c'était un manque ablement la chronique
d'une mort annoncée de la nouvelle
négociation de l'assurance chômage et je
le crains la chronique d'une mort
annoncée de 50 ans de paritarisme dans
notre pays
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à votre collègue julien
bargeton pour le groupe de la république
en marche
monsieur le prix monsieur le président
monsieur prémunissent mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
christelle du boss l'endométriose
concerne français sur 10 de tous âges
c'est une maladie chronique qui touche
uniquement les femmes et qui se
manifeste par des douleurs gynécologique
récurrentes et souvent handicapante
cette maladie reste encore trop méconnu
aujourd'hui le diagnostic est réalisé
avec un retard moyen de 5 ans ce qui
laisse la maladie gagner du terrain
elle est encore trop souvent révélées
après un bilan de fertilité donc à un
stade bien avancé
car c'est une maladie qui ne se guérit
pas 40% des femmes atteintes sont
infertiles les causes de la maladie ne
sont pas réellement identifiés et les
traitements disponibles ne sont pas
pleinement satisfaisant on peut
facilement mesurer les souffrances
physiques et morales de l'endométriose
sur les femmes concernées et leur
entourage
les témoignages des femmes font état de
situation d'isolement et de détresse
allant même jusqu'à compromettre leur
vie professionnelle
nous avons beaucoup à faire pour
améliorer la qualité de la prévention de
cette maladie ces prochaines années
c'est un chantier qui est devant nous il
faut ici saluer l'engagement décisive
des associations notamment en offrant ce
qu'ils ont voulu briser le silence et
médiatiser cette maladie de l'ombre
par définition si intime et donc si
sensible ces associations se sont
mobilisées la semaine dernière lors de
la semaine européenne de l'endométriose
via des campagnes de sensibilisation
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
le gouvernement a présenté une feuille
de route ambitieuse le vendredi 8 mars
pour faire de l'endométriose une
priorité de politique de santé publique
davantage qu'un simple drame privé
pourriez vous indiquer quelles en sont
les principales avancées nous
communiquer si cela est possible des
éléments de calendrier et la façon dont
les élus seront associés je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à mme le secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des solidarités et de la
santé valable du boss merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
l'avez rappelé landes hommes
l'endométriose touche plus d'une femme
sur dix c'est une maladie complexe
douloureuse mais surtout invisible est
trop silencieuse elle est encore trop
méconnu par les femmes mais aussi des
professionnels ce qui engendre souvent
des retards de diagnostic des errances
médical dont les femmes sont les
premières victimes
à l'occasion de la journée des droits de
la femme et pour clore la semaine
européenne de prévention et
d'information consacrée à cette maladie
agnès buzyn a visité vendredi le centre
de l'endométriose de l'hôpital saint
joseph et il a annoncé un plan d'action
construit autour de trois axes notre
premier objectif est de détecter
précocement cette maladie en intégrant
la recherche de signes d'ennui trio dans
des consultations dédiées à la santé
sexuelle des jeunes femmes entre 15 et
18 ans et en renforçant la formation sur
les signes d' alerte le diagnostic et la
prise en charge dans la formation
initiale et continue des professionnels
de santé concernés
le deuxième axe vise à mieux accompagner
les femmes et rendre simple et cohérent
les parcours de soins aujourd'hui vous
l'avez décrit les parcours de soins sont
trop erratique la prise en charge de la
douleur et des troubles de la fertilité
devront aussi faire l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière afin de mieux
répondre aux légitimes inquiétudes
enfin nous voulons mieux informées cette
maladie encore trop méconnu au
complément des campagnes de
communication et des associations il
nous faut mieux faire connaître la
maladie et sa prise en charge
en mobilisant notamment le service
sanitaire des étudiants en santé pour
informer les élèves dans les collèges et
les lycées sur la maladie et
sensibiliser les futurs professionnels
de santé l'ensemble des parties
prenantes seront associés aux travaux de
mise en place de ce plan d'action votre
objectif est donc simple apporter des
réponses concrètes aux femmes touchées
par cette maladie complexe et
douloureuse et qui la vivent aujourd'hui
souvent en silence faute de diagnostic
ou de prise en charge adaptée si
monsieur bergeron
[Applaudissements]
la part le net à notre collègue marie
mercier pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
la question est importante alors je me
permets d'y revenir
1 millions 4,1 millions 400 mille
entreprises artisanales
en france nous sommes fiers de nos
artisans
nous sommes tous fiers de leur
compétence de leur savoir faire
nous sommes fiers de leur
professionnalisme ce sont eux qui créent
les richesses qui créent l'emploi qui
accompagne les jeunes qui assure la
formation des entreprises
mais madame la ministre votre réponse ne
m'a pas vraiment satisfaite
il y a un problème qui n'est pas résolu
depuis des mois comme l'a dit notre
collègue c'est celui de leur formation
la formation professionnelle est une
nécessité
la formation professionnelle il paie
pour ça les cotisations elle passait par
les services fiscaux
ça marchait pas trop mal mais maintenant
que ça passe par les sur saft ça ne
marche pas bien du tout il y a un
déficit de plus de 30 millions d'euros
et pourquoi et bien 177 mille adresses
d'entreprises ont mystérieusement
disparu des fichiers cela n'est pas
tolérable
nos artisans va le mieux que ça qu'allez
vous faire
madame la ministre concrètement parce
que j'aimerais une réponse pour eux
qu'ils soient plus satisfaisante
pour vous répondre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame agnès pannier rue
nash et secrétaire d'état madame la
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
je vais revenir sur ce que je vous ai
indiqué peut-être que mes mathématiques
n'étaient pas suffisamment précises nous
parlons donc de 42 millions d'euros de
cotisations a récolté qui sont des
cotisations dues par les artisans ils en
ont payé 9 millions d'euros
je pense que ça leur fait 33 millions de
trésorerie c'est probablement une bonne
nouvelle pour eux j'ajoute que sur ses
33 millions d'euros vous en avez 15
millions qui ont été prises en charge
par l' agence france trésor et 18
millions par l'acoss l'agencé france
trésor le prêt a été remboursé les 18
millions d'euros de l'acoss ils sont
toujours là 15 + 18 33 plus 9,42 le
compte est bon
alors pour aller plus loin que sommes
nous en train de faire puisque la
discussion est de savoir si nous allons
plus loin il nous demandons aux artisans
de payer des cotisations dont ils sont
légalement redevables et ce n'est pas un
sujet date rêves perdus vous l'avez bien
compris c'est un sujet d'acceptation de
paiement de ses cotisations au titre de
leur rôle de chef d'entreprise et au
titre de la rouge de salariés avec la
question posée par l'ordre des experts
comptables donc plusieurs pistes
complémentaires sont actuellement
habitude pour remédier à ces difficultés
le gel du remboursement des avances de
trésorerie effectué par l'acoss et ça
c'est l'état qu'il porte
18 millions d'euros alors que la loi ne
le prévoit pas la possibilité d'une
contribution exceptionnelle en 2019 de
l'agefiph fonds d'assurance formation
des chefs d'entreprise aux échappées ou
face à eux à leur rappel des règles de
contribution au fonds en vigueur pour
les artisans
et puis vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice de rappeler combien les
artisans sont importantes dans ce pays
et combien ils contribuent à la fois à
la vie économique mais également au lien
social sur les territoires c'est pour ça
et je me permets de leur rappeler que le
gouvernement s'est mobilisé avec des
mesures d'urgence dans le cadre des
gilet jaune et très vite dès novembre et
qu'il a également dans le cadre de la
loi pacte prévu un certain nombre de
mesures qui me semble très structurante
je vous remercie
madame marie mercier
madame la ministre je ne prétends pas
être spécialiste en mathématiques
par contre mon métier c'est de soigner
les gens de soigner les patients et je
soigne des artisans c'est une profession
qui aussi est en souffrance comme les
agriculteurs
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'investir dans l'avenir
l'occasion vous est donnée ne nous
décevez pas la parole est à notre
collègue michel dagbert
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice madame la ministre madame la
garde des sceaux au terme du grand débat
voulu par monsieur le président de la
république pour répondre à la crise des
gilet jaune
il ne vous aura pas échappé que pour une
grande majorité d'entre nos concitoyens
doutent de la capacité des seules
institutions à apporter des réponses aux
grandes questions du moment
au delà du doute nous pouvons considérer
dans leur expression qu'il y a même une
forme de défiance à l'égard de la
communication des institutions publiques
comme de celle des grandes entreprises
privées faisant leur la phrase devenue
célèbre d'une humoriste
on ne nous dit pas tout c'est pour
répondre à ce besoin d'une information
objective que des femmes et des hommes
se sont exposés pour rendre publics des
faits répréhensibles par notre droit les
plus connus à la robert hervé falcini
stéphanie gibeau ou encore irène frachon
peuvent être considérés comme les
précurseurs de ce qu'on appelle
communément les lanceurs d'alert dans
ces conditions l'accord trilogue
parlement européen conseillent
commission européenne intervenu hier 11
mars sur la directive relative aux
lanceurs dallaire sur la base de la
proposition de notre collègue virginie
rosières doit être salué
pouvez vous madame la ministre nous
éclairer sur la position que défendra la
france dans trois jours c'est à dire le
15 mars sur cette question pour vous
répondre
madame le garde des sceaux bis de
justice si vous avez la parole sur
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur dagbert je vais tout vous dire
je vais vous dire que vendredi dernier
lorsque j'étais au conseil justice et
affaires intérieures à bruxelles j'ai
répété que la france souhaitait
clairement l'adoption rapide de ce
projet de directive avant les prochaines
élections
ce texte qui est inspirée de la loi
sapin de protégera plus efficacement les
lanceurs d'alert dans l'ensemble des
pays de l'union
la france a toujours soutenu le principe
d'un texte unique au champ d'application
large coup franc de très nombreux
domaines d'action de l'union y compris
d'ailleurs la fiscalité
l'essentiel de la directive fait donc
aujourd'hui l'objet d'un accord avec le
parlement européen
il restait un point de divergence sur la
hiérarchie des canaux de signalements le
conseil au sein duquel d'ailleurs la
position de la france n'était pas isolé
le conseil souhaitait conserver comme
principe parce que c'est d'ailleurs
l'état de notre droit en france
l'obligation pour le lanceur d'alert de
référer d'abord en interne
non pas nécessairement auprès de son
employeur mais auprès d'un interlocuteur
impartiale tenu à une obligation de
stricte confidentialité nous qu'on sent
en effet que c'est ainsi qu'il peut être
mis un terme le plus rapidement possible
à une violation dénoncé et c'est
d'ailleurs le cas dans la majorité des
situations ce principe était assortie
d'exceptions extrêmement large
permettant aux lanceurs d'alert de
signaler directement les faits auprès
d'interlocuteurs externe syndicats
défenseur des droits lorsque le
signalement interne risque et par
exemple de l'exposer à des représailles
ou bien de faire disparaître des preuves
contrairement à ce qui a pu être
mentionné dans les médias ces derniers
jours
la france ne souhaite pas retarder
l'adoption de ce texte c'est pourquoi
nous avons accepté de supprimer cette
hiérarchie des canaux de signalement
nous allons ainsi parvenir un texte
assurant une protection maximale des
lanceurs dallest
tout en instituant un mécanisme
juridiquement solide et proportionnées
aux différents niveaux de gravité des
signalements effectués
nous touchons au but avec un accord en
vue d'ici vendredi
jeux divers merci madame la ministre
nous voici rassurés parce que comme vous
l'avez mois mentionné un article du
monde samedi ils n'avaient pas manqué de
nous étonner voyant la france partagée
sur ce texte les mêmes réticences que
l'autriche et la hongrie
le banc sur lequel je m'exprime et
nombre de parlementaires reconnaissent
difficilement les arguments que vous
aviez alors avancé pour justifier d'une
timidité sur le sujet nous reconnaissant
bien mieux dans cette citation de jean
jaurès
le courage c'est de chercher la vérité
et de la dire merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue jean-marie
janssen pour le groupe de l'union
centriste lever la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
notre pays traverse depuis plusieurs
semaines une crise sociale grave qui
traduit l'inquiétude profonde de
beaucoup de nos concitoyens difficultés
économiques et sociales disparités
progressive des services publics dans
les communes poids de la fiscalité
sentiment d'injustice devant les
inégalités sociales les motifs de
préoccupation sont nombreux et
alimentent parfois la colère des
français comme vous mes chers collègues
je sens depuis longtemps monter le
souffle de la contestation dans mon
département de loir et cher ceci au sein
de la population comme chez les élus
locaux
l'une des origines de ce malaise se
trouve dans la fracture territoriale qui
ne cesse de se creuser entre la france
des grandes villes et celle des
campagnes et des petites villes
ceci n'est pas une vue de l'esprit
c'est une réalité du quotidien dans les
petites communes rurales les habitants
voient leurs services publics
disparaître et les distances de trajets
s'allongent et le sentiment d'isolement
et même d'abandon gagne nos campagnes ce
sentiment est partagé par nos élus
locaux extrêmement sollicités mais qui
manque cruellement de moyens et de
soutien en ces temps difficiles où les
principes fondateurs de notre république
sont remis en question
c'est précisément le moment de nous
appuyer sur le formidable tissu d'élus
locaux pour établir les calibres
territoriales pour cela il est
primordial de réaffirmer et de renforcer
le principe de décentralisation inscrit
à l'article 1 de notre constitution
oui l'enjeu premier de la révision
constitutionnelle dont nous débattrons
prochainement et bien la
décentralisation
elle est la clé d'une confiance renoué
entre les territoires de la république
elle est le point de départ d'un nouveau
contrat républicain
aussi ma question est simple ferez vous
de la décentralisation la clé de voûte
de la révision constitutionnelle à venir
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à marc
fesneau ministre en charge des relations
avec le parlement qui répond à domicile
allez-y si monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean saine nous
avons en partage la connaissance du loir
et cher et pas seulement 7,7 se
partagent la simplement essayer de vous
répondre en deux temps la première chose
que vous avez parlé de décentralisation
et peut-être essayer de repartir de ce
qu'on peut percevoir déjà même s'il faut
laisser dérouler un certain nombre de
choses autour du grand débat la première
chose c'est ce qu'on peut percevoir des
attentes des citoyens
parce que c'est bien de ça dont il faut
partir parce que c'est bien de ça dont
vient la crise
la première chose c'est une demande de
proximité la demande de proximité
s'exprime au travers d'une demande de
proximité des interlocuteurs ils veulent
savoir qui sont les gens à proximité que
ce soit dans les collectivités co2
locales ou l'état
ils demandent aussi une proximité des
réponses c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'ils une question qu'ils soient posées
il trouve l'endroit où il peut se faire
les nouvelles technologies sont un outil
mais ce n'est pas le seul outil faudra
regarder à humaniser le service et ils
demandent enfin une proximité au travers
des services publics ça c'est la
première question posée par les citoyens
la deuxième question et reconnaissons
que l'oeuvre collective que nous avons
pu faire depuis des années n'a pas tout
à fait aboutie ils ont de maurice ont
besoin de lisibilité
l'enchevêtrement d'un certain nombre de
compétences à succession d'un certain
nombre de réformes n'ont pas clarifié
les choses pour les citoyens ils ont
besoin de lisibilité parce qu'ils ont
besoin de pouvoir identifier les
responsabilités
il n'y a pas de lisibilité sans besoin
d'identifier les responsabilités pour
pouvoir rendre des comptes pour ceux qui
sont en responsabilité et aussi pour que
les citoyens puissent s'exprimer s'est
exprimé face à eux et puis ils ont
besoin troisième point de confiance la
confiance dans les institutions des
acteurs locaux et donc à la façon dont
ça fonctionne la confiance entre les
acteurs locaux et l'état et puis la
dernière confiance et la simplification
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on fasse
confiance aux gens ce sens à chaque fois
normes et les choses et à ceux qui
portent des initiatives et pour ça il ya
trois outils et pour répondre à votre
question et a les outils de la
décentralisation qui permet de réfléchir
à quel est le meilleur endroit où on
peut exercer la compétence et la
question à l'intérieur de la
différenciation on a trop centralisée la
décentralisation si je veux dire il faut
qu'on puisse adapter selon les
territoires
la répartition des compétences et la
façon dont elles s'exercent et puis à la
question là que la déconcentration parce
que j'entends et nous entendons aussi
sur les territoires
grand besoin d'états de présence de
l'état et sur un certain nombre de le
sujet c'est l'état lui-même qui est
interrogé dans sa présence territoriale
et dans son action et d'ailleurs même
les collectivités réclament souvent les
thaïs donc c'est sur ces trois piliers
là qu'il faudra répondre dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent merci
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je tiens à saluer la présence de notre
hémicycle pour sa première séance de
questions au gouvernement devant la
marie pier richer sénatrice du cher qui
remplace notre collègue françois pile
est désormais membre du conseil
constitutionnel
je lui souhaite la bienvenue au sénat et
je salue également le retour parmi nous
de madame josiane cause qui remplace
notre collègue jacques mézard également
devenu membre du conseil constitutionnel
[Applaudissements]
prochaine question d'actualité le 21
mars à 15 heures
je vais suspend la séance elle sera
reprise à 17h50 pour la suite de la
deuxième lecture de la proposition de
loi visant à renforcer et garantir le
maintien de l'ordre public lors des
manifestations
la séance est suspendue
et voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité où les sénateurs ont
interrogé le gouvernement sur la crise
algérienne alors que le président
algérien abdelaziz bouteflika a renoncé
hier à briguer un cinquième mandat
consécutif
mais pour le président des sénateurs
rdse jean claude requier ce recul n'est
pas suffisant pour répondre aux attentes
de la population algérienne car
l'élection présidentielle qui était
prévue le 18 avril a été reporté a
reporté de plusieurs mois à la fin de
l'année 2019 alors le premier ministre
edouard philippe lui a fait une réponse
beaucoup plus optimiste il a salué
l'esprit de responsabilité du
gouvernement algérien et le calme des
manifestants et des forces de l'ordre
et puis il a dans les mots dans les
mêmes termes que le président l'a
publique emmanuel macron demandé un
calendrier raisonnable pour réformer le
système politique algérien autre temps
fort de cette séance de questions
d'actualité la question de la sénatrice
communiste
catherine apourceau poly sur la
privatisation de la société aéroports de
paris une privatisation qui avait été
rejeté et déjà par le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale va rétablir cette
mesure demain dans l'examen de la loi un
pacte alors la sénatrice communiste
accuse le gouvernement de brader un bien
d'intérêt stratégique national qui est
bientôt le deuxième groupe aéroportuaire
européen
benjamin griveaux le porte parole du
gouvernement lui a répondu en rappelant
que l'état garderait un contrôle sur le
futur gestionnaire notamment en termes
de sécurité et de qualité de service et
noté que la ministre de la justice
nicole belloubet a affirmé que la france
soutiendra bien la future directive
européenne de protection des lanceurs
d'alert alors que certains observateurs
faisait état des réticences de la france
aux côtés notamment de l'autriche sur ce
projet de directive européenne
la ministre de la justice a donc apporté
un démenti
voilà des films pour les temps forts de
cette séance de questions d'actualité
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes vos
précisions et on continue à les
réactions avec vous au thème traduit
puisque vous et à vos côtés deux ans
michel leblanc caire le ministre de
l'éducation nationale c'est à vous oui
jean michel blanquer vous avez
d'ailleurs été interrogé sur ce sujet à
l'instant l'organisation de débats sur
le climat dans le lycée vendredi
pourquoi faire tenir ces débats dans les
lycées ce jour même de grève mondial
contre le climat vient justement parce
que c'est une grande journée pour le
climat mais qui me paraît très utile que
les lycéens puissent non seulement dire
leur attachement à cette question c'est
le sens de la de la grande manifestation
mais en plus contribué par des débats et
par des propositions
or je sais très bien que nos élèves ont
beaucoup de choses à dire sur le sujet
et que nous pouvons en tirer profit pour
des propositions concrètes surtout dans
ce contexte de grands débats où c'est
l'objectif que d'aller vers des
propositions concrètes
donc non seulement il y aura la journée
du 15 mars avec le débat de 16 heures à
18 heures mais en plus toutes ces
propositions pourront être cristalliser
le 5 avril lorsque nous réunirons mais
délégués lycéens de france dans une
réunion pour les biens de synthétiser ce
qui aura été dit certains doutent de
l'efficacité d'une telle mesure ils
disent les lycéens ils seront en grève
toute la journée vont ils revenir entre
16h et 18h dans les lycées dans
l'objectif est pas qu'ils soient en
grève toute la journée je suis dans mon
rôle de mimi de l'éducation nationale en
disant que c'est quand même mieux de
rester au lit ses débuts je n'incite pas
à rater les cours bien au contraire et
par contre je ne sais il y avait une
certaine bienveillance pas raciste je
viendrai très grande bienveillance
vis-à-vis du thème bien entendu et des
lycéens qui n'ont pas cours le ca peut
arriver le vendredi après midi mais
peuvent très bien y aller de même il y
aura des étudiants et il y aura la
jeunesse c'est très bien mais si on
accourt on accourt et et et on peut
faire plus que manifester en participant
aux débats et donc c'est le sait le sens
où ça c'est d'une certaine façon la
convergence de différentes façons de
participer
comment vous allez organiser la remontée
d'informations de tous ces débats sur
ces délais qui reste très court c'est le
prime de lancement du grand débat
oui mais dans le jeu dans chaque lycée
vous avez un comité de vie lycéenne
c'est de la démocratie lycéenne que nous
faisons vivre toute l'année et ce comité
de vie lycéenne donc pourra établir un
document dans chaque lycée qui remontera
vers les régions vers chaque région nous
avons un comité académique et ensuite la
synthèse régionale viendra dans ce
comité de vie lycéenne nationale que
nous aurons le 5 avril ça
salue cette proposition mais juge que le
gouvernement a une politique bien timide
sur les questions environnementales
c'est une politique d'hésitation de
report 10 tartas prenant notamment
l'exemple du projet de loi énergie que
leur répondez vous non je crois que
beaucoup de choses ont été faites par
exemple je parlais ce matin justement
dans un grand débat avec des jeunes
d'une école de la deuxième chance à tour
du fait qu'on avait grâce à l'action de
la france et d'autres pays
une directive qui permet d'interdire
trois pesticides qui sont tueur
d'abeilles au diable on pourrait citer
beaucoup d'exemples de choses qui ont
été faites
l'action de françois de rugy de brune
poirson d'emmanuel wargon beaucoup de
choses sont faites on peut faire
peut-être encore plus et plus vite mais
ce gouvernement a déjà un bilan
environnemental très positif
bien entendu il faut faire plus et la
jeunesse peut être le vecteur de ce plus
parce que j'étais récemment dans un
collège à conflans sainte honorine
on voyait les jeunes qui proposait
comment dépenser moins d'énergie en
réglant d'une certaine façon les
lumières comment dépenser moins pour le
chauffage etc
ils ont divisé par deux la facture
d'électricité de leur propre
établissement
ensuite ils ont une influence sur leur
propre famille sur leur commune donc on
peut avoir une contagion positive depuis
la jeunesse pour des solutions concrètes
pour l'environnement
eh bien merci beaucoup jean michel
blanquer d'avoir répondu à mes questions
est également non loin de moi l ya le
président du groupe l air au sénat le
sénateur bruno retailleau voilà qui
salue d'ailleurs jean-michel bloquèrent
bruno retailleau
bonjour alors vous êtes la personne dont
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui puisque
notamment hier le président de la
république a annoncé saisir le conseil
constitutionnel sur la proposition de
loi dite anti casseurs que vous avez
porté et qui a depuis été modifié par
l'assemblée nationale
votre réaction je veux dire que l'objet
du texte il n'est pas du tout un big
n'est pas du tout équivoque c'est de
faire en sorte que en france on puisse
manifester librement pacifiquement sans
craindre les minorités ultraviolente
walla alors le prion république se
saisit l'article 31 de la constitution
qui lui permet de faire appel du conseil
conscio neil mais en réalité qu'est ce
qui se passe
il se saisit du conseil conscio neil il
en appelle au conseil constutionnel
entre un texte qui a été repris par son
premier ministre et qui était même
renforcer l'article de même durci par
son ministre de l'intérieur c'est plutôt
drôle
j'imagine que il veut pas non plus
laisser à la gauche le soin de saisir le
conseil constitionnel cet article de
tout de même est ce qu'il ne pose pas
problème tel qu'il a été modifié par
l'assemblée nationale philippe bas le
président à l ère de la commission de
lois juge qu'il est allé trop loin je
précise qu'il porte sur l'interdiction
administrative de manifester écoutez moi
je pense que si demain on a pas en
france pour nous forces de l'ordre pour
la république même et pour la démocratie
des outils qui nous permettent de lutter
pied à pied de ne pas céder un pouce de
terrain à ces minorités ultra violente
alors vous verrez c'est le droit de
manifester qui sera touchée il n'y a pas
de hasard si ces dernières semaines on a
entendu des voix qui se sont élevées
pour réclamer l'interdiction des
manifestations
on atteint un dilemme soit demain il
faudra interdire les manifestations soit
ce que je préfère ne pas les interdire
les autoriser mais en revanche en
revanche éradiquer celles et ceux qui se
cachent qui se dissimule derrière leurs
cagoules pour commettre leur forfait
alors ce texte vous le jugez réellement
satisfaisant tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
vous qui l'aviez tout de même vraiment
critiqué lorsqu'il était à l'assemblée
nationale non j'avais critiqué la sortie
en commission des lois
mais le texte sorti en commission des
lois n'a plus rien à voir avec le texte
qui ensuite été voté par les députés
évidemment il n'est pas totalement
parfait et c'est pas notre texte mais je
pense qu'on aura un esprit de
responsabilité
on veut très vite par souci d'efficacité
voter ce texte le vote est conforme pour
que encore une fois on puisse avoir des
instruments qui permettent à nos forces
de l'autre et la justice de lutter conte
ce contre cette nébuleuse ultra violente
c'est une toute dernière question votre
réaction au rapport annuel de jacques
toubon qui parle de climat de répression
en france et qui à nouveau dit qu'il
faut interdire les lanceurs de balles de
défense et les certaines grenades qui
sont utilisés aujourd'hui par les forces
de l'ordre dans les manifestations quand
il ya des dérives il voyait voir
évidemment des enquêtes y en a plus de
110 je crois à l'heure actuelle j'aurais
simplement rappeler qu'il ya eu et le
ministre de l'intérieur nous l'a redit
tout à l'heure mille cinq cents
policiers gendarmes et sapeurs pompiers
qui ont été blessés ils ont peut-être eu
aussi droit à notre attention
merci beaucoup bruno retailleau d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
si beaucoup tam pour cette réaction et
on va prolonger sur cette question de la
ppl anticasseurs avec mon invité loïc
hervé bonjour sénateur union centriste
de la haute-savoie ça vous fait réagir
ce que vient de dire bruno retailleau
vous allez vous voter contre c'est pas
la position de votre groupe d'ailleurs
nous sommes une grosse dizaine dans le
groupe de l'union centriste à vouloir
nous abstenus ou ont voté contre ce
texte
considérant que la rédaction de
l'article 2 est une rédaction qui n'est
pas précise qu'il n'est pas applicable
et que nous ne faisons pas un bon
travail de législateur nous au sénat qui
devons être vigilants sur les libertés
publiques sur l'applicabilité la qualité
de la loi donc des réserves que j'ai
exprimée en dans la discussion générale
qui est d'ailleurs toujours en cours
devant le sénat et puis cette surprise
d'apprendre et hier qu'elle président de
la république fera usage de l'article 61
comment vous l'interprétez mois pour moi
c'est très simple saisine du conseil
constitutionnel par les mois c'est très
simple le sénat n'a pas fait n'a pas
joué son rôle de protecteur des libertés
publiques dans ce texte ce que le texte
qui nous revient d'assemblée nationale
n'est plus le même que le texte qui
avait été voté au sénat et en
choisissant de voté conforme ce texte
nous rendons un service à la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale qui elle même à
des atermoiements sur ce sujet et ne
faisant pas ce rôle là on offre
président de la république une occasion
incroyable de finalement joué le bon
rôle est de dire je suis moi-même
présent la république protecteur des
libertés individuelles et donc le
présent se saisit de l'article 61 de la
constitution et décide avant même que
nous ayons même délibérer et voter de de
saisir le conseil constitionnel en dix
ans bah dites des finales pour les
opposants à cette loi dont vous faites
partie c'est une bonne chose cette
saisine du conseil
je pense que le conseil constitutionnel
trouvera dans les débats du sénat cet
après-midi tous les arguments
nécessaires pour trier le bon grain de
l'ivraie et dire ce qu'il y a
de bon dans cette danse loi on peut le
dire la question de la lutte contre les
cagoules et puis d un certain nombre de
de renforcement du saulcy un bruno
retailleau été très clair finalement si
ces articles les plus sensibles vous le
disiez sur l'interdiction administrative
et manifester sont censurés elle n'a
plus lieu d'être il n'y a plus de
propositions de loi et donc le sénat
n'aura pas joué son rôle d'amélioration
de la loi s'il ya un débat l'assemblée
nationale entre les parlementaires de la
majorité parfois vingt neuf au
rétablissement de la rédaction du texte
voté par le sénat en première lecture et
que l'assemblée nationale fasse son
travail
il sait très ambigu ce qui se passe sur
cette question là et c'est le elle est
liberticide en l'état cette loi loïc
hervé j'utilise la passe qualificatif je
n'ai pas utilisé la discussion ne veut
pas l'utiliser ici
en tout cas elle pose un certain nombre
de problèmes en termes de libertés
publiques
mais c'est essentiellement dû à la
mauvaise rédaction de la loi
il suffit de lire l'article 2 si nos
téléspectateurs veulent la lire c'est un
texte une phrase extrêmement longue
on parle d'agissements j'ai regarder
dans le dictionnaire agissements ça ne
rien dire agissements c'est des
manoeuvres policiers disent qu'ils en
ont besoin notamment et bien pour mettre
un terme à ces violences dans le cadre
des manifestations des gilet jaune des
manifestants les plus violents les plus
extrêmes
vous avez beaucoup de juristes disent
que le droit actuel suffit nous verrons
si cette loi est constitutionnelle et
qu'elle entre en vigueur le parlement se
saisira au titre de son pouvoir de
contrôle de la situation et nous verrons
si cette fois vraiment changer les
choses
moi je crois qu'elle ne changera
malheureusement rien et que je suis très
inquiet sur même sa sa conformité à
notre droit nous sommes un pays qui a
mis du temps à conquérir ces grandes
libertés publiques et c'est toujours une
affaire d' équilibre entre l'ordre
public qui doit être garanti et aussi la
capacité pour l'état de permettre à nos
compatriotes qui le souhaitent de
manifester je pas moi même un grand
manifestons jeu manifestions séquelles
les discussions particulièrement vivant
notamment l'élu centriste de la main de
charles de courson
il ya dix ans se croit revenu sous le
régime de vichy vous dernier la même
chose c'est un ami donc je partage
beaucoup de choses avec avec charles de
courson les termes qu'il a utilisée ils
sont aussi liées à l'histoire de sa
famille sa grand mère est morte en
déportation peut on peut comprendre que
sur ces sujets là il est une sensibilité
tout à fait particulière les mots qu'ils
utilisent dans sa bouche c'est pas
forcément ce que j'utiliserai mois mais
ont rouvert ge sur l'analyse que nous
faisons ce texte le parlement peut
renforcer la garantie de leur public
sans avoir recours aux pouvoirs du
préfet à la juridiction administrative
alors que pour de notre côté c'est
plutôt à la juridiction judiciaire de
garantir les libertés le sénat et il est
le l'ordre juridictionnel qui est
l'ordre judiciaire défendent davantage
les libertés publiques
traditionnellement que d'autres est ce
que tu te sens seul e siècle de suivre
des députés en mars à l'assemblée dit un
préfet n'a pas du tout envie de voir sa
décision contestée donc il doit faire ça
dans la mesure où ne fait pas confiance
à l'autorité administrative justement
pour prendre des décisions justifié je
fais confiance à l'administration mon
pays
actuellement nous sommes dans un état de
droit je pense que les préfets sondés
préfèrent républicains pour la quasi
totalité d'entre eux par la totalité
d'entre eux mais je voudrais pas que
nous fassions entrer dans notre droit
des dispositifs qui serait facilitant
d'action si demain d'autres gouvernants
prenait le pouvoir et pas très claires
j'ai pas envie qu'on fasse le lit de
marine le pen
loïc hervé c'est aussi l'actualité en
étant la dernière ligne droite du grand
débat on sait qu'il ya ces conférences
thématiques nationales qui sont
organisées je vous propose d'écouter
bien un des garants de ce grand débat
pascal perrineau il a été nommé 1
proposée par gérard larcher pour bien
encadrer ce grand débat il est assez
critique un jeu propose à l'écouté la
communication gouvernementale et
présidentielle s'est prolongé tout au
long du débat elle collège des garants a
fait savoir que cela pouvait avoir un
impact celui d'introduire
un doute chez les citoyens et des
citoyennes qui auraient envie de rentrer
dans ce processus du grand débat
national en disant en font ce processus
du grand débat national n'est pas
suffisamment neutre donc au nom de la
neutralité
le collège des garants à rappeler
jusqu'à une date tout à fait récente
qu'il fallait bien distinguer ce qui
relevait de la communication
gouvernementale d'un côté et de l'autre
côté du processus de consultation
citoyenne qui est le processus du grand
débat national
il ya des interférences de la part de
l'exécutif du gouvernement avec le chef
d'état qui a beaucoup monopolisé les
temps de parole notamment dans les
médias c'est ce que dit pascal perrineau
j'ai rencontré pascal prévôt plusieurs
reprises parce que je fais partie du
comité de suivi du grand débat national
soit comme centriste au titre de la même
formation politique soit comme
secrétaire général des petites villes de
france donc à plusieurs reprises on a
été convié à matignon et monsieur
pérenno étaient présents je partage ce
qu'il vient de dire stark en fait le
débat c'est 15 janvier 15 mars
donc le débat doit s'achever dans les
jours qui viennent
et donc il est nécessaire que maintenant
les choses s'interrompre en bon ordre
quand il présentera les publics décident
de prolonger de trois débats quand on
décide de faire in extremis un débat
dans les lycées vendredi après midi
quand on commence à quoi à dire que il
débat n'est pas fini mais mais il est
finie quand même il ya eu il ya une
complexité il faut que le débat s'arrête
en je le redis 1 d'autres bonnes
conditions et que la communication du
gouvernement d'une part la fin du grand
débat d'autres pas et surtout je dirais
la campagne européenne puisse prendre sa
place dans le pays le débat démocratique
il doit laisser la place à la campagne
européenne regagné l'hémicycle on
retrouve nous justement alexandre
poussin puisque la discussion de cette
proposition de loi anti casseurs a
repris alexandre oui delphine
initiateurs vont parler dans quelques
instants de l'article 1er qui prévoit
des fouilles des manifestants à l'entrée
à l'entrée les manifestations et
certains cet article 1er il sera examiné
par le conseil constitutionnel sur
demande du président de la république
alors le texte du sénat en première
lecture prévoyait que le préfet
décide de ces fouilles mais il a été
modifié par l'assemblée nationale qui
souhaite que des agents de police
judiciaire organise ses contrôles sur
demande du procureur de la république
une mesure donc un peu différentes mais
qui va être votée normalement dans sa
version conforme par la droite du sénat
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
précisions c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi et puis la
rédaction de public sénat elle s'associe
à cette semaine à l'opération une
jonquille pour curie pour soutenir la
recherche contre le cancer vous pouvez
d'ailleurs faire un don en envoyant par
sms au 92 00 2 le mot espoir on compte
sur vous bones eu des programmes à vous
et à demain
[Musique]